estava numa grande dúvida do falaram
após brasil o futebol é é a primeira vez
que ouvi falar após o dado foi fazer o
gol logo dizia que no futebol o que hoje
é verdade amanhã é mentira e por isso
com esta nota do stand up é eu pretendo
pedir um dos objetivos fundamentais em
qualquer comunicação que entrar nem o
segundo grande objectivo é vencer lá e
vamos ver se eu consigo mais aqui uns
bons minutos mas entregou esta
brincadeira por saulo muito facto após o
tornado que é um conceito que
aparentemente nem vai ter cenas assim a
palavra do ano 2010 é só isso
vamos unir os apelos emocionais e as
convicções mais do que os factos na
criação da opinião pública
aparentemente temos que acreditar que
isso possa acontecer e foi descobrir
visitou vitória do time fazem acreditar
mais no campeonato faz apelos emocionais
as convicções poderem usar em termos de
opinião pública não acreditar que os
factos mesmo mas nós mundo das redes
sociais que mais contemplou - aquilo que
tínhamos na lista como eu velho
atendendo prioritariamente
aliás as redes sociais temos penso que
há mais informação eu filho e neto
todavia eu sugiro o exercício faz muitas
vezes ainda fiz apenas a tentar perceber
até que ponto quando luiza alguma
informação clay numa rede ou a partir de
uma rede social 11 em qualquer no
twitter no facebook
op estava na relação da manhã e surgiu
uma notícia estou completamente
inventado não estava escrito em um papel
mas é só para tentar proteger as mãos
daqui a pouco estava na praça manara
dizia e surgiu uma notícia que o permite
que seja votado ainda não tenho certeza
mas como não tenho certeza que nós
aparentemente deu essa notícia de que o
cristiano ronaldo ia doar 3 milhões de
euros às famílias das vítimas do
desastre aéreo no brasil qual é primeiro
a obrigação do jornalista é livre é um
dos nossos princípios é a verificação
das notícias a primeira verificação que
eu fiz é aquela que muitos nós fazemos
ver uma notícia como suja
mas no facebook designadamente o que
deixa lá ver a fonte a fonte um bloco
deve ser uma coisa anos também está
relacionada portugal isso não tem nada
contra o nome até divertido pode ser
feito por gente muito muito sério e
competente e agora nós quer economizar
pode ser eu não conheço a verdade é que
eu não conheço não válidos a mesma
maneira e normalmente nós temos um tipo
de notícia destas e por baixo
a fonte é imaginem new york times o caso
vença o sp
o ciclo ii mas nós acreditamos mais
naquilo que vai em comum carimbo que nos
habituaram que seja o caminho da verdade
querendo provar nada passe algumas
rodadas quiserem não parcial quero dizer
mais provisória é o carimbo dos média
tradicionais toco almocei ituanos
acontecer e por isso nós não podemos
desprezar esta dimensão enquanto os
paulistas que temos aos olhos do público
e nós fomos criando lançador de
informação e quando há informação se
multiplica tanto e e corrigem tantas
fontes é nossa capacidade a nossa
autoridade para sermos veículo de
canonização obriga nos a um trabalho
ainda mais aturado do discurso do
esforço no sentido de fazermos bem
aquilo que é nossa grande missão a nossa
missão tem vários princípios
recentemente foram estimulados a nível
mundial foram reformulados os grandes
princípios do taoísmo nós vamos sair com
isso nós já que ninguém quer tirar um
curso mas mas vou falar nos voltando
aqui o futebol porque ficou famosa a
intervenção nunca disse treinador com 36
não é isso
antes disso eu já usava três carros mas
eu sempre dei aulas e fiz algumas formas
falava aos meus alunos daquilo que o
campeão 36 nos ajudou muito e são o
conhecimento é competência e
criatividade estava o próprio nome e
avales quiser pra qualquer um das nossas
atividades
a base de tudo é o conhecimento ninguém
está confortável abordar o assunto eu
por exemplo aqui falar se não tivesse
alguma vez pensaram espiritualiza
e todo o nosso conforto resulta de algum
conhecimento que nós temos dos assuntos
e nós somos também estou mais
confortável não somos tão mais como
antes quando abordamos temas de que
gostamos e que dominamos
isso é fundamental para fazermos o nosso
trabalho ninguém é bom fazer alguma
coisa que não gosta
o primeiro não é muito bom tempo a
cumprir pode ser eficaz mas foi
particularmente bom fizeram o que não
gosta ou que não domina o primeiro
esforço que nós temos eu penso muito
nisso no meu mundo as notícias deve
crescer é conhecer um mundo muitas vezes
estagiários chegar na sala junto com o
encontro que a primeira a primeira
vantagem de um espírito de longe de
mostrar a eles que ela estava em tantas
empresas nas nossas vidas é capacidade
de fazer esse trabalho melhor que
qualquer outra pessoa e nacionalismo
está em uma dimensão óbvio que a
conhecer o mundo
o uso é uma esperança jornalista que
conhece o mundo não sabia onde ficava a
mania que és a cronologia das filipinas
sábado deixou o treino
sabe que o brasil acompanhe pelo menos
passar qualquer coisa da síria está mais
habilitar ou então que sabe que o
tribunal constitucional está mais
habilitada a fazer um jornalismo do que
um miúdo que não sinta só pelo
conhecimento de que conhecimentos
quiserem no sentido mais lato tanto
quanto partida conhecimento só em cima
do conhecimento nós aplicarmos a nossa
competência
se acontecer o técnico nossas
ferramentas
ninguém é pública é uma ferramenta de
gestão de uma empresa se não tiver
conhecimento de estampas vêm a seguir e
depois a questão da criatividade é o que
nós conseguimos por causa do nosso num
determinado não treinar trabalho é que o
que faz com que trabalho seja diferente
de um de um outro qualquer e portanto
eucalipto que base da nossa capacidade
de fazer vai em qualquer circunstância
são estas conhecer primeiro o mais
sólido ser competente tecnicamente
habilitá lo e no fim ter alguma coisa
mais surdo em áreas pv não quero não
quero ser pretensioso falar então lembro
de ver com alguma dimensão artísticas
que não tarde estica se quiser voltar ao
futebol dimensão artística em algumas
atividades em algumas áreas naquela das
quais ruas
genericamente todas as áreas da
comunicação
o jornalismo também ano e aqui posso se
quiser voltar ao futebol porque eu acho
que este ano escreve um livro tem a
pretensão de escrever um livro nunca
tinha escrito um livro sério escreveu um
livro chama precisa de futebol sério e é
séria e tem evolução mais 300 páginas
para quem estava comendo não porque era
vender mais o objetivo de vendas mais ou
menos atingir quem estará com ele porque
vai valer sessão ele vai poder pensar em
qualquer coisa isso tudo aprender mais
qualquer coisa
a questão do conhecimento e por muito
que eu acho que gosto vamos suficiente
que vai ser o suficiente para perceber
qualquer coisa
mais uma vez a questão do conhecimento
todo mundo trabalhando pra mim lá fui eu
ver uma série de jogos que já tinha
visto ver algum antigo na mente que
nunca tinha visto e ler muita coisa
designadamente sobre tempos em que nem
sequer era possível ver por que não
dizer se algo não estavam sequer filmar
e essa busca de mais um pouco de
conhecimento no roma a descobrir ou
redescobrir o primeiro sistema tático
foi uma coisa que era um novo tanto o
guarda redes um defesa e depois novos
jogadores alinhados no meio-campo
começava ocorrer quando a equipa tinha a
bola e voltavam para trás quando aqui
para 1 ea evolução da tática e se
quiserem estátua que é um pensamento
sobre o jogo fez sempre assim da frente
para trás foram inspirando os jogadores
da frente para trás e estatuetas foram
sendo cada vez mais desequilibrada e
menos inclinadas para frente pois é
engraçado porque nós acabamos por ser
por exemplo um sistema muito famoso
bicho é o pai dos sistemas de jogo eu
explico isso de maneira simples pra
todos entenderam que há uma semana de
abril é no fundo é o design de um dom
luís 1 e no entanto 2332 no campo mas o
guarda redes
os três jogadores mais defensivos
passaram tornar se um dia 4 mais uma vez
rondônia entanto a defesa
depois nós eu particularmente já
chegamos a ouvir falar no quarto fez o
quarto filho é precisamente isso não era
mais um defesa central eram o quarto
elemento ou para a defesa pois há uma
história extraordinária também que os
húngaros é uma justiça que se deve fazer
foram também determinantes na evolução
do futebol tenha havido o domínio era
total da vila mas a inglaterra numa
grande equipa no final dos anos 30 do
século passado pois os austríacos têm um
homem genial chamado mais é o primeiro
grande pensador do jogo em termos de
no fim do jogo também nos anos 30 uma
pessoa extraordinária e depois um dos
poucos anos 50 é conseguem de fato de
pegar no jogo e dar lhe uma dimensão
antalya por exemplo são zumbis levam um
sistema jamais e rui é o chamado 424 ver
além dos quatro vezes
havia mais de dois meses a coisa estava
mais de cuidado leva os problemas pois
até trazer para portugal com o homem
fomos vice da última que ele sai o
cruzamento do brasil para portugal e
para treinar pouco sábio pela primeira
vez no topo do corpo
no primeiro anel de campeão no porto e
só por ser campeão português atrás do
gol enfim vamos voltar ao benfica e
torna se vice campeã da europa os dois
grandes tipos que dois fazem o melhor
momento da história da história do
benfica e só melhor logo quando chegou a
portugal
as equipes ainda estavam com cinco na
frente e é o senhor que tem aí eu também
neste caso do chá mais um para trás do
benfica foi chamado mário coluna quando
eu era avançado e passou a ser o médio
centro mais influente do benfica e do
futebol português marca anda para lá
estudar isso trouxemos aqui um exemplo a
acreditarem que o mesmo né é e pára pra
pensar mas também isto é evolução do
jogo fez muito sempre o conhecimento que
os treinadores em andamento quiseram ir
tendo do jogo eo jogo acabou por ter um
uma como apogeu técnico ou seja as
melhores equipas do mundo em meados do
século passado eram o real madrid porque
juntou uma série de jogadores que eram
extraordinários para quem sabe o
movimento externo com parra em formosa é
de 90 no fundo acho que não estava mas
também tínhamos jogadores é o apogeu da
técnica o benfica também foi muito tempo
essa geração extraordinária no brasil a
viu o fogo o santos pelé que também
ganhava tudo e este apoio do técnico e
vai até 1970 quando uma grande equipe do
brasil lugar no mundial do méxico com os
jogadores do santos reais
ela é a frente dos outros mas o
jairzinho rivelino gérson tostão e fiz
gols que fazem parte da grande história
do futebol como verdadeiros artistas
depois vem o apogeu da da dimensão
física no jogo só começou a importar é o
saber de outras modalidades
designadamente o atletismo mas também da
última fila ia muito saber desenvolvido
a oeste das grandes escolas
educação física e então as equipas do
oeste e as equipas de países do norte
apostar fortemente na condição atlética
também porque em alguns casos pessoas
naturalmente mais atletas mais altas e
eu tivemos uma posição do físico é que
as equipas inglesas região mas até na
hora de encontrar em programas com os
ingleses do minuto depois chegamos a uma
fase vai desde os finais dos anos 80
desde os anos 70 do século passado em
que a tática passou a ser muito muito
valorizada
houve um grande confronto e itália entre
os lugares mais uma marcação homem a
homem que são a zona a zona ganhou ainda
hoje mas se vê as grandes equipas do
mundo marcam mais a zona do que o homem
após contatos no minuto só consegui
contar essa história no mínimo 30 restam
cinco para dizer que ainda quer dizer
assim
o homem usou um treinador genial e
argentino chamado césar luis menotti foi
campeão do mundo em 1978 em um dia
explicou às pessoas qual é a diferença
entre a zona e o homem eu sou titular
dinheiro presentes e os cavaleiros que
não gostam de futebol
vou contar uma história do menor porque
op o menotti chamou o jogador não era
problema muito votado pelo menos um
ponto fundamental
eles vão explicar é assim tu tens um cão
de guarda
então frost dois ladrões querem assaltar
a casa
o cão atacou correr atrás dos ladrões
falei com os ladrões fogem o persegue o
ladrão o outro entretanto prossegue a
porta ficou aberta e vai exaltar a casa
fez um outro campo não é tão feroz e por
isso sempre que o jogador está próximo é
apenas um ladrão não apoia nenhum mas
também entra em casa o primeiro marca o
homem o segundo marcador zona
o jogador ficou ilhada e conta a lenda
que nunca mais jogou na equipa do metal
nossa história é ótima para percebermos
que o facto todos os grandes saltos e
usei o exemplo do futebol porque é algo
que me agrada particularmente são sempre
por capacidade de pararmos para pensar
não é porque eu tenho de correr atrás
alguém já viu um caminhão chamado
vitória mas nota no futebol que dizia
que isso é humilhante para o jogador
fazer chamadas marcas ao homem quer que
diga não sou eu é a minha missão do
campo e correr atrás do outro
eu sou mãe no tom e na como eu pode
jogar um qualquer e portanto quando foi
se esvaindo
e de repente agora vou ficar aqui na
minha casa aumenta carro porque eu quero
dizer aqui uma série de nomes
vocês pensam josé mourinho andré
villas-boas falando de sangue
jorge jesus vítor pereira rui vitória
paulo fonseca marco silva 0 no espírito
santo paulo sousa quer avaliar o paulo
bento carlos queiroz antes eu também só
auferiu é um exemplo
esta gente toda a defesa e ganha no
mundo
o mundo vai em portugal os caras trazem
para serem campeões em paragens tão
bonzinhos como a terra o méxico egito a
suíça e el grandes carreiras em espanha
e tal e porque mais desatento o senhor
do fenômeno diz aqui um buraco do ozono
positivo em portugal e então acha que
trabalhadores são todos os momentos
fantásticos e geniais precisamente por
foi desenvolvido um conhecimento em
portugal muito específico que fez com
que o juiz aqui uma uma série uma
geração de pessoas mais qualificadas do
que a maior parte dos preços em outros
países há um conhecimento cruzam saber
empírico no jogo com o saber acadêmico é
desenvolvido primeiramente anunciado o
jogo chamadas a colaborar com esse lado
humano e mais tarde na faculdade porto
porto
nenhuma tem um desenvolvido uma teoria
do treino muito associada à idéia do
jogo e esta foi uma grande emoção no
futebol não vou entrar era muito
pormenor livros apenas quem nunca ouviu
falar da privatização tática ainda têm
muito a aprender sobre a atual proibição
tático é precisamente o conceito
desenvolvido a partir da faculdade porto
porque eu estudava em tese de
doutoramento no mundo inteiro com
estudantes do lado haveria que perceber
como é que afinal os portugueses treinam
não treinam todos paralisação tática
provavelmente o mentor da presença da
prevenção que é um profissional junto à
frase até aquela data que maior parte
deus treinar coisas que não têm nada a
ver com o que eu queria mas a verdade é
que houve uma profunda reflexão sobre o
autoisolamento comum mas ao mesmo tempo
extraordinário e sim no mundo inteiro
que eu e foi feita a prática de portugal
e que mudou
momento o pensamento sobre o jogo ea
forma de atuar sobre o jogo
desde logo a partir do treino é mais uma
vez a questão do conhecimento que nos dá
ferramentas para a competência e depois
sim a criatividade fernando santos teve
de ser muito criativo para ganhar o
campeonato da europa não é aquilo também
algum momento nós pensamos que só com um
milagre no mínimo muita criatividade
ameaças e luisão os 23 jogadores 21 sol
e patrícia que não deu hipóteses aos
dois guarda redes suplente os outros
jogaram todos aqui foi mesmo andar ali é
criar eleitoralmente soluções jogo a
jogo ea procura sempre de uma função da
criatividade muitas vezes mas
fundamental esforçava num conhecimento e
muita competência para gerir um grupo de
pessoas e para treinar esse grupo de
pessoas importantes no fundo a minha
viagem virtual também foi para nos
trazer de volta aqui o parceiro mais
importante porque quando falo em
conhecimento e competência e
criatividade se calhar estou a falar no
fundo dimensões nunca fiz mais
filosófico como ética do conhecimento
nos permite ser rigorosos fomos nós
cumprimos melhor que o que são as nossas
obrigações para com a rodada eliminou o
espetáculo com os outros para com os
outros
isto é a ética é pura desligada do
trabalho do jornalista
se formos competentes para fazer
dominamos a técnica e só deve ser
criativos tocamos até tem para
embolsarem província que é nosso tem a
nossa assinatura é a nossa marca é claro
que há outros e que não esquece e a 55
já posso dizer e que é absolutamente
determinados técnicos trecho até três
meses ao quarto e o 4º c é que o que faz
com que muitas vezes os outros três
valeu a pena e se não existir pode não
valer a pena nenhum dos outros tem mais
a ver com a nossa opção e dado o caráter
e e absolutamente vital que temos e ser
de coragem sem coragem para usar para
nós atravessamos prass carlos para
pensarmos diferente para passarmos do
total nacional porque não porque não
pensar de outra maneira
possivelmente competência conhecimento o
criatividade só não chega portanto o meu
desafio é que tenhamos isso mas sempre
que foi preciso coragem também votar
obrigado
[Aplausos]